Now, in this section, we will look at modification tracks, which will serve as a precursor to
what we will use in Unreal Engine to control sequencer editorial transitions.
Starting out, there are two modification tracks that we are going to focus on.
And the first is the level visibility tracks.
Level visibility tracks can control the visibility of any level or sublevel, and is used to switch
between various lighting setups or comps, different staging layouts, and effects.
Level visibility tracks can also be used in conjunction with the material parameter based
transitions controlled through sequencer to create cinematic transitions like the crossfade,
to achieve a perceived passage of time, create match cuts, or make location changes.
One thing to note though is that if your levels are very heavy, you might see a delay as the
assets load into the level.
The next modification track that we are going to look at is the material parameter collection,
or MPC.
And in order to get deeper access to the myriad of properties a static or skeletal mesh actor
may have, you'll want to access its mesh components.
Exposing the mesh components can help you keyframe specific properties in sequencer
such as an asset's material settings.
Properties like material elements can be exposed and controlled transitionally and
blended through sequencer.
Or material switcher properties can be exposed and allow a user to switch between materials
applied to the mesh through sequencer keyframes.
One thing to note, the switch is an on or off option and cannot be blended like you
can with material elements.
Now let's jump into the engine and take a look at the modification tracks in action.
So let's move over into the mod tracks folder and take a look what's set up for you in this
folder.
Inside this folder you will find two material parameter collection assets, two level sequence
examples and a folder containing two more level sequences that will be used as sub-sequences
to demonstrate animated action in the modification tracks examples.
The parameters collected in the MPC Car Paint will be used in the Material Parameters level
sequence.
But we're going to start out with the level visibility track level sequence.
Double click to open the level visibility track.
And then lock the camera to the cinematic viewport so that we can see what's happening
within our camera.
Next move over to the levels tab.
It's next to the outliner.
Turn that on so that you can see the persistent level, broadcast, desert, oasis and rally
sublevels.
The broadcast sublevel is not going to be affected by the level visibility track.
But before we play through this level sequence, let's move down to the sequencer controls
and turn on playback looping.
This way the desert and oasis sublevels will turn on and off as we play through our transition
a few times.
This will give you a chance to make sure that you can see the eyeball icon in the levels
tab turn on or off for each sublevel.
If we stop and move through the level sequence more deliberately, pay attention to what's
happening in the viewport.
If we move first from the desert into the active desert scene and then from the desert
into the oasis scene, you will see assets appear in the sublevels as you move from section
to section.
Note, for any of this to work, the sublevel track requires an array to be added to the
properties of that level visibility track and the sublevel name must be manually typed
into the index field.
Spelling is a factor here, so be careful to get the name exactly correct.
Of the array in the visibility field, you will be able to switch between hidden and
visible inside the pulldown menu.
This is how you switch between each section, but each switch requires another copy of each
of the visibility tracks themselves.
You'll notice a breakpoint between these as the two tracks are turned on and off.
Alright, now let's look at the material parameter collections as a modification track.
First double-click to open the material parameters level sequence.
This level sequence is going to use the same action subsequence track, but by adding a material
parameter track to the level sequence from the tracks button, the material parameters
have been exposed to sequencer, allowing access to the parameters to make changes that can
be keyframed in sequencer.
Again, by adding these tracks from the track menu in the material parameter collection
and choosing the MPC car paint that we've got, we are able to keyframe these on our
timeline and make changes to our transitions.
In this collection, we have loaded a vector parameter.
By using the plus button and choosing the vector color.
This color option exposes the RGB values and allows us to choose a 0 to 1 value to modify
the car paint.
As you can see the keyframes here change the value of the car paint.
And as we did before, let's lock our camera to our viewport and make sure the looping
is enabled in sequencer and play the level sequence.
As the SUV travels through the level, you can see the keyframed car paint blend from
one color to the next.
If you are interested in how to create material parameter collections, there is a materials
course that is available for this specific topic.
I encourage you to check that out as you continue your Unreal Engine training.
Alright, that's it for sequencer modification tracks.
In our next section, we're going to take a look at using modification tracks for editorial control.
Thanks for watching!